éditions à 20h20 mais avant ce tour du
monde allant dans le sud est de la
france où je vous le disais de
nombreuses régions ont souffert et
souffriront ce soir encore de fortes
averses nous équipe conduite par nicolas
winckler and protein et françoise vallée
se sont rendus respectivement dans le
vaucluse les bouches du rhône et
l'ardèche
ce qu'ils ont vécu la nuit dernière
ressemble un épouvantable cauchemar en
milieu de soirée des pluies diluviennes
ont fait sortir de son lit la rivière
qui traverse pertuis une lame d'un mètre
70 qui a emporté la digue en amont du
village puis tout dévasté sur son
passage
400 personnes ont été évacuées elles ont
parfois tout perdu
je crois que les inondations ont fait un
mort un homme victime d'une crise
cardiaque au moment de son évacuation
ce matin c'était la colère dans ce
quartier hlm
c'est la troisième fois en six ans qu'il
est dévastée par les flots le canal qui
suit la route
il en profite pour qu'il y ait plus
d'une innovation soi-disant des
drainages de votre pays si y'a rien qui
a été fait guerrier sith avant de
recoller jamais dû être construit sa
voix y avait peut-être un peu trop
d'argent à prendre quelle ctv des vignes
qui avait ici une source
ils ont embrasé les vignes et le permis
construire ce même camp et l'ange
ce soir les habitants de père qui sont
inquiets météo france annonce en effet
de nouvelles précipitations pour cette
nuit la pluie a repris cet après midi
une pluie dense mais beaucoup moins
forte que les énormes averti hier soir
une pluie qui n'a pas véritablement
contrarier la décrue amorcée dans la
journée depuis ce matin l'eau descend
peu à peu mais elle laisse derrière elle
des traces témoignant de sa terrible
force à aix l'accumulation de trois
mètres d'eau a transformé ce garage en
champ de bataille vous à transporter des
voitures winter ligue 1 depuis john 5
comme des fétus de paille
c'est sur la route que l'orage a été le
plus meurtrier deux personnes ont trouvé
la mort au volant de leur voiture
et ce matin des centaines de véhicules
bordel et route d'aix-en-provence
abandonnés par leurs propriétaires
plusieurs axes routiers ont été coupés à
cause des éboulis et des chaussées
défoncées provoquant de gigantesques
embouteillages
pas de répit non plus pour les chemins
de fer et les voies aériennes de train
ont déraillé et l'aéroport marseille
provence a été fermé pendant la nuit ce
soir de nouvelles perturbations sont
attendues difficile d'en prévoir
l'intensité à la préfecture au préfère
être trop prudent que pas assez
les habitants des bouches du rhône sont
donc invités à rester chez eux ce soir
on a frôlé la catastrophe hier soir à sa
race au nord de valence
un train de marchandises en provenance
de marseille a déraillé sur un pont au
dessus de la nationale 86 à quelques
dizaines de mètres seulement des
habitations
les pluies torrentielles qui se sont
abattues hier sur la région sont à
l'origine de l'accident
une coulée de boue a dévalé la colline
entraînant avec elles des troncs
d'arbres sur les voies
sur les 31 wagon 14 sont sortis des
rails
le conducteur de la motrice a été tué
sur le coup maurice odier 49 ans
travaillant dépôt de dijon était père de
trois enfants
depuis hier soir le trafic ferroviaire
est interrompu la nationale 86 a été
coupée une déviation
été mise en place le temps de sécuriser
le site de nouvelles pluies sont
annoncées dans la région